very very excited about it yes yes we
all are nfl player and award-winning
host emmanuel acho his groundbreaking
series uncomfortable conversations with
a black man aims to fight racism he sits
down with everyone from matthew
mcconaughey to little wayne for a real
and honest conversation the online
series launched less than two years ago
and check this out it has already hit
more than 90 million views and counting
now ocho has put out a new book a new
book because he has multiple illogical
saying yes to a life without limits it
challenges people to shift their
mindsets manny watcho joins us right now
what's up baby
yo this is my family like my real
actual
looking good thank you for joining us i
know you're making your runs but let's
talk about this book because you say
that you describe your life in one way
and that's let me say how you say it
being illogical
i'm watching y'all check out the
instagram he didn't do that yeah
he pulled it from down here
very very that's awesome i saw that too
but all jokes aside though why do you
describe your life like that because i
like so many people have failed and
failed time and time again but i had to
reframe failure nate you can relate to
this it the nfl combine i tore my quad
muscle i ripped it off the bone for
those at home the nfl combines the
biggest audition for the sport that owns
one day of the week why it was so
devastating because i set a goal yo i
did what we all do i set a goal after my
junior year in college gail and i said i
will be drafted in the first three
rounds but after tearing my quad
i failed on my goal self-esteem ruined
devastated dejected and at that point in
time i said i'm going to be illogical
i'm done setting goals from here on out
i'm just going to have an objective with
no limitations because a goal starts
with an end in mind gail and that to me
made no sense most people don't think
being illogical makes sense either in
fact you're encouraged as a kid growing
up not to be a lawyer
but you you sort of flip that on its
head
you take things in your life where you
said talk about goals you wanted to be
homecoming king and you wouldn't be
athlete of the year you didn't get
either one of those but i like what you
said setting a goal is dumb because what
you should really do is have an
objective with no limits when chasing
your dreams don't aim for anything yeah
it's i say why aim for something when
you can have anything because think
about it y'all were just talking about
this dating application what we all do
is something along the lines of this 20
help in dating no
he said no real quick
a lot of my home girls said hit me up
nate i know you know emmanuel i know i
seen him with his shirt off mine too are
we done that's what i'm happy okay go
ahead go ahead
i can't stay in jail
what we all do is this at 26 yeah i want
to be married at 28 i want to have kids
at 30 i want my first home but what
happens when you're 31 vlad and you
don't have any of those things now
you're questioning your self-esteem your
self-worth i say have an objective with
no limitations a goal is an end towards
which energy is aimed and objective is
just energy in a direction so from here
on i just put my energy in a direction
that's what being a logical is about is
helping people rid themselves of these
goals which we've been indoctrinated
with you gotta have a goal little timmy
right right rid yourself of the goal and
live a life without failure what i love
about your journey is that you've had to
suffer to come to the realization of
these insights i mean you've gone
through some things and that is what has
led you to come up with these life
lessons man cut five times by the time
that's right by the age of 25 yeah i was
drafted at 21 traded at 22 cut five
times at 25 for those at home that can't
relate to the nfl experience nate i know
you can imagine being hired straight out
of college right transferred and then
cut by your employer five times all by
twenty fired by airplanes exactly
but now what i've realized
um now what i've realized though and i
thought about this one day you didn't
fail you fell as long as you get up you
win
and so many people think well i failed i
failed i failed you didn't fail yeah you
just failed yeah and as long as you get
up and keep moving forward you win
realistically speaking our greatest
accomplishments in life they come on the
other side of our logic so what is that
conventional wisdom everybody's told you
you can't nate i know so many people
told you you couldn't right and so what
is that that people are trying to tell
you you can't do that you just have to
go be illogical and do yeah when life
takes unexpected turns you said start
playing a different game different rules
your own
even illogical about eating rice with
peas
eating rice
i thought even something like that
simple was really the book starts like
this all the things we've been
indoctrinated with 1400's renaissance
era beauty was defined as pale skin thin
lips large forehead uh dark hair yeah
but now in the 21st century beauty is
defined as sun-kissed thin a naturally
skinny waste etc why because we let
other people's significance have so much
significance in our lives yeah but why
do we let insignificant people have so
much significance so gail to your point
why do we eat rice with a fork in theory
what's more practical is to eat rice
with the spoon true that's logical here
we go well listen i'll leave everybody
with this cause i love this don't let
other people's fears become your own
that's right that's money hey we
appreciate you manny manuel acho
thank you illogical on sale now go get
it this amazing book appreciate your
brother